I'm Olivia Lee and a profitable
behavioral and brain sciences I xmas a
university in France and I'm here to
answer a question that was asked on
Facebook by Alan Wooders about the
future direction to contribute to
improving the state of the world that's
quite a question let me talk about an
initiative that started years ago by
some younger leaders and who decided to
create global dignity a task force that
allows kid to give their impression
about dignity what is meaningful for
them in life what is that goal in life
etc so this is a great initiative that
you really need support and I encourage
you to go to global dignity org thank
you